c'est sûrement un règlement de comptes
parce que moi je veux j'ai voulu garder
cette cuisine de tradition oui assure
parlait toujours de la nouvelle cuisine
c'est difficile donc il faut que faire
tomber des têtes 6 mio peut-être
médiatique et s'il fait pas tomber des
têtes c'est pas possible un dernier à la
fait tomber berger cette année il fait
tomber bocuse il fait tomber le nôtre
c'est bien parce que ce sont des gens
médiatique depuis combien de temps vous
n'avez pas du christ terminaux est bien
inscrit 5 millions avec son chien ou son
chien
ça fait 18 mois je me rappelle plus le
nom de nom de son chien mais
dernièrement d'un télé venue avant il
avait beau pour goûter donc il se fiait
surbourg sur le palais 2 go sur le goût
de beau aujourd'hui la plus go away il a
pris un chien avec lui c'est un espèce
de sprint cher est assise sur ses genoux
le chien gouttes en même temps que lui
quand le chien bouge là que une fois sa
barre deux fois trois fois celle sommes
donc le chien apple dû bouger la cub
deux fois à la maison et j'ai dû ramer
mais je parle sérieusement qu'ils
m'apportent dans ma vie de cuisinier
c'est pas savoir si j'aurais gagné de
l'argent ça va si j'ai trois tops ou cap
toc ou une cuillère ou le coq la tête
coupée parce qu'un accord des coques en
a donc tout le monde limite tout le
monde c'est de savoir si j'aurai
transmis car dans ce métier est un
métier de compagnonnage et rend ce match
est beaucoup plus important que des
films occupé des guides